encrypted phone networks using secure
handsets
are being cracked by police exposing
thousands of alleged drug dealers
details
but lawyers say the evidence has been
illegally obtained
and can't be used in court here's what's
behind the encro chat
and sky crypto phone hacks and how it
might affect
your right to private communication it's
a bad time to be a drug dealer police
across europe have been carrying
out a wave of coordinated raids
in february across germany hundreds of
officers searched
dozens of properties including here in
berlin
seizing drugs and weapons and closing an
alleged cocaine taxi operation
last year dutch police said they found a
torture chamber
while dismantling drug labs along with
thousands of kilograms of cocaine
and crystal meth in the united kingdom
almost
1 000 people have been arrested tens of
millions of pounds in cash
seized and fleets of luxury cars
impounded
uk law enforcement say it's their
biggest operation
ever it's all because of the demise of
encro chat
a crypto phone network encroachat
used modified android handsets with
hidden operating systems
activated by pushing the power and
volume buttons
users could send encrypted messages
across a closed
network the camera and gps were disabled
a panic code could wipe the device in
seconds
incra chat handsets costs around a
thousand euros up front and
1500 for a six-month contract
an estimated 60 000 customers had signed
up
but in june last year encrochat sent out
an emergency message
to its users destroy your phones
we can no longer guarantee the security
of your device
you are advised to power off and
physically dispose of your device
immediately french police had managed to
hack
into ankara chat's servers and install
malware
directly on the user's handsets
collecting millions
of seemingly secure messages through
europol
they shared their discovery with police
across the continent
enco chat wasn't the only crypto phone
system
after it went down users switched to sky
ecc on sky devices
users logged in to a stealth mode
operating system
using the calculator messages could be
timed
to self-destruct skyphone promised a 1
million dollar reward for anyone who
could hack the system
someone did in march 2021
belgian and dutch police announced that
they had cracked sky ecc
and had been monitoring messages for
weeks
it's a big blow because we've been able
to read the messages live over the past
three weeks
plans for killings plans for drug
transport
plans for large scale money transports
we will be able to dig into this gold
mine of information
over the next weeks and months i believe
this investigation shows that criminals
are wrong in thinking that they can stay
outside of the view of the police
has been indicted by a u.s grand jury
and is wanted for arrest
but he claims european police cracked a
copycat
system not under his control skyphone he
says was a legitimate private
communication tool
and the raids are a threat to many
people's freedoms
privacy and protection of information is
the foundation of the effective
functioning for many industries
including legal public health
vaccine supply chains manufacturers
celebrities
and many more and some lawyers agree
there's nothing illegal about using
encrypted communication
most of us do it every day whatsapp is
encrypted
so too are signal secret chats
german defense lawyer ulrich summer
represents several people
charged with crimes following the
anchorage at raids
i have a right to telecommunications as
does any citizen
this can only be interfered with if
certain conditions are met
such as there being an initial suspicion
against me
i assume that in this case all
conceivable rules have been disregarded
the investigators not only violated laws
but also human rights
and that's why the whole outcome is in
my view not usable in a proper
criminal trial
[Music]
yesterday was anchor chat today was sky
tomorrow
it'll be whatsapp and after that the
telephone network i'm really appalled
about the impact on society
now belgium police have asked skyphone
customers to come forward
if they were using their telephone for
legitimate ends
normally innocent people don't have to
ask to be excluded from investigations
so why should we care if alleged drug
dealers are being tracked down
well ulrich summers says many people
legitimately need to use encrypted
communication
for example lawyers journalists and
political dissidents
he says these police operations are
putting them at risk
and are eroding privacy
if you fled russia because you were a
political dissident
would you trust your email service or
call over the regular phone system
no you'd take steps to protect your
communication from some nosy russian
hackers
that's not only legitimate that's even
necessary to protect your fundamental
rights
you and i have every right to make use
of exactly that encryption nobody can
forbid us from doing that
defense lawyers are planning to fight
these cases
all the way to the european court of
justice
with anchor chat and skyphone hacked
what comes next
no doubt a new encrypted phone network
will emerge
and quickly become a target for police
hackers
you